[Music]
crispy treat that means nothing honestly
I've never heard the word crispy treat
without right I think of when my mum
would make crispy treats with like
melted chocolate and corn flakes
I like homemade rice crispy treats I
don't like the store ones that come in
those with blue little full foil
packaging the packaged ones are really
really good like slaving over that pot
it's so sticky but so worth it
I'm expecting sweetness but who knows
it's BuzzFeed's
oh look at that that is awesome
it looks reddish so I'm guessing
sriracha okay so this looks like honey
nut cheerios can I taste some cinnamon
I'm just hoping it's not insects oh
she's cool here well get that with the
store-bought ones this is definitely
pumpkin flavor Cheerios pumpkin spice is
that what it is pumpkin spice Cheerios
this is a dream come true this is really
good did you make it you have cheese
it's okay oh wait that's actually really
good
whoa the sweet and the salty and the
cheesy taste so good together
oh my god
I thought it was macaroni like macaroni
cheese this already looks like a green
invention it already looks very
appetizing but it's funny were you high
when you made this
[Music]
okay it's already sticking to the plate
what is this a monstrosity oh this looks
so gross this was like somebody sneezed
on this plate
that's meat this is beef jerky
why so gross you unlock a marshmallow
casing and then you just fill your mouth
with this juice of dried meat I can't
let's just looks too horrible what is
that
it's like cheese and ham this is
definitely Turkey there's a marshmallow
in this I see some sesame seeds on here
which makes me think it's like Chinese
takeout
I smell salad dressing okay though I
mean it tastes like a frozen salad kind
of but machine no you can't Rice
Krispies a turkey sandwich all right so
how about that my least favorite was a
beef jerky for sure just cuz it looked
like alien throw-up cereal or bust okay
so here's the thing about crispy treats
right three ingredients rice krispies
marshmallows and butter long as you keep
that simple that formula will work you
start adding other things in you had a
sandwich to that you're playing with
fire and you're gonna get burned you're
gonna burn it bad